everybody welcome back to another
episode of awesome build because
Halloween is right around the corner and
all the Halloween stores are starting to
open up I thought I would do another
archive episode of me taking a cheap
Halloween store hockey mask off the
shelf and repurposing it and making a
cool steampunk mask also I kind of
skipped over it in the Mad Max review
because I really wasn't something I had
any footage of and I didn't spend a lot
of time on but a few people did inquire
about it a lot of people were kind of
curious that's how I made the blood bag
mask for the review I don't have any
footage of me building it because I
built it really really quickly there's
one of those things where Doug didn't
request it as a build it was something
that he didn't really feel he needed but
when he was doing the scene when he was
running through the cave he just
requested that he had some kind of a gag
or a bandana or something to wrap around
his mouth because that's really what was
more happen in the movie but I thought
it was a missed opportunity because so
much of like the posters and the images
that you saw were of Tom Hardy or Mad
Max with that mask on so I said I think
it'd be better if you went with the
blood bag mask and he said well did you
make one and I said no so but if you
give me you like 20 minutes I can slap
one together so yeah this is it and all
it is is I took some scrap pieces of
plastic some thermoforming plastics that
I use and just really quickly I drew in
a piece of paper the shape of the trowel
or the like fork and cut out a paper
quickly tracing really crudely cut it
out of the plastic and I made the side
brackets just quickly cut them out of
plastic I didn't measure anything was
all eyeballed just because when I was
running out of time and - I figured it
didn't matter it was going to be
something that I had a look like it was
thrown together or made out of scrap
parts anyway so the connecting brackets
here is just some foam and then all of
the rivets and stuff are gemstones you
can buy at like Hobby Lobby or Michaels
or jo-ann fabrics or one of those kind
stores they're like a self-adhesive
stick on gemstone and they come in
different kind of shapes and sizes I've
used them for rivets and stuff like that
before they work great and then I just
did a really quick dry brushing with
some gray spray paint I sprayed and just
with a sponge I did some quick dry
brushing to give it that kind of
metallic look and slapped a scrap piece
of elastic hon there and that's it
I was really quick it's kind of throwing
together and it was comfortable enough
for a Doug to wear it and still be able
to talk and stuff like that so it was
the last-minute build so unfortunately
as I said I don't have any footage of it
but I think it took about 20 minutes I
get really just slapped it the other
really quick I would like actually to
make a little bit more detailed version
of it because I think it would be a
pretty cool it's an easy cosplay kind of
thing to do just wear this get a fake
chain with a piece of that clear tubing
and run some dye through it and yeah
we're a shirt and you've basically got
your costume so that's how that was done
and the archive build is going to be on
this steampunk mask that I made I don't
think we've ever used it in a review or
anything was just a fun build and I've
been planning on using it for something
in the future but so far just doesn't
happen so I hope you guys enjoy this
little archive episode
so let's not waste any more time strap
on your goggles and let's go we're gonna
do a half mask and our basis for it is
gonna be I got it at Party City it was
like five bucks so we're just gonna kind
of map out the design or the shape that
we want cut it using our rotary tool and
then add some off-the-shelf type items
and give it a new paint job I'll go over
a few more of the smaller items we're
gonna use a lot of stuff is gonna be off
the shelf we're just gonna modify it a
bit by maybe making some changes any
places where it would normally be
painting it so forth all right some of
the other items that we're gonna be
using on this I got as I said these
almost all like off-the-shelf die pieces
I'm gonna use these gemstones they look
cut in half
they've got self adhesive on the back
and these are gonna make great rivets
I'll also be using some various spare
parts that you can find at Michael's or
probably jo-ann fabrics and some various
just sort of ornamental kind of
decorative pieces we're also gonna be
using probably some of these compression
fittings these brass compression
fittings that are used in the past for
the star-lord helmet and some other
various pieces of hardware some scrap
leather you can get this at generally
Michaels or jo-ann fabrics you can
usually buy a bag of it for like twelve
bucks and it's got a various parts like
just scraps like this that are leftover
they've got a ton of this stuff and
always comes in handy I've used it for
all kinds of projects okay so the first
thing that we're gonna do is we're gonna
kind of plot out on the mask where we
want to make our cuts as I said I'm just
gonna do a half mass so I'm probably
just going to use the bottom section I'm
not sure exactly how this mask is gonna
look right now I'm just gonna start kind
of playing around with different parts
and see what looks good
all right so here's the piece that I cut
off I made some extra lines here using a
mask that I went around the shop to
cover it and give me a basic idea of
where my face is actually gonna be in
the mask because the way that this piece
right now is the little too wide and
I'll show you what I mean okay so the
mask is basically gonna go over the face
like this but these pieces kind of flare
out a little too much what you could do
is use a heat gun and heat up the edges
where I've made the lines and kind of
bend it back so it actually forms around
the face a little bit better
but to kind of save on time I thought
maybe I would just cut these pieces off
and use the scrap leather to make the
sides of the mask and that will tie
right into the strap and the buckle for
the back but if you wanted to you could
actually cut that piece off and add a
hinge which actually sounds like a
pretty good idea and maybe I might do
that if I have time maybe I'll make more
than one mask we'll cut these corner
pieces off put leather behind it and add
a hinge there so that it folds around
the face a little bit snugger and we
could put like a decorative hinge on it
will actually add some texture and some
character to the mask cool I think we're
gonna do that also kind of neat is the
top of the mask that you used to cut it
off actually can become another pretty
cool mask a little bit more like sci-fi
kind of looking but yeah that's kind of
a so you had two masks out of one
basically for a future project or
something alright so after I've cut out
the corn pieces as is over left with so
this would be the part that covers the
face and
these end pieces that I cut off we're
going to actually hinge and then I'll
put some leather behind it and we'll
attach the straps to that leather for
hinges I've got these cheap well
relatively cheap I think there's not
four but I don't know they were three or
four bucks at a happy store they're kind
of these cool decorative hinges so
that'll be what I use to add the two
pieces and I think they'll give it kind
of a cool look okay so I drilled holes
and temporarily put the hinges on using
these little fasteners that it came with
just to kind of give an idea of how
last-minute how like it's gonna look and
if that's the look that I want to go
with I think actually it's gonna look
pretty cool and so now I'm gonna measure
and cut the leather for the back of it
for the back of this piece and then
we'll kind of figure out what we're
gonna do with the mouthpiece again I
don't want it to look like a hockey mask
so we're gonna find some elements to
kind of decorate this but so that we can
still breathe okay so I drilled out my
whole pattern for where I'm gonna put my
ribs my ribs or fasteners and I'm gonna
attach the hinges and some other
decorative pieces here and then what I'm
going to do is take these tiny gemstones
they have that self adhesive on them but
they really don't stick very well but
you can kind of put them in place where
you want them to see how it looks first
and then yeah because it does look the
year going forward you can take them off
or mark where they are and then glue
them with superglue before we go ahead
and paint so I'm going to do that now
I'm gonna apply the rivets kind of
around it to give it a look and and see
where it goes from there
all right now that it's painted I went
ahead and added the hinges I used these
little press opinions that it came with
that kind of opened up and and I just
once they were open and pretty tighten
where I thought I wanted them I just had
glue them on the other side cuz we're
gonna cover this with some cheap leather
and stuff anyway all right so what's the
scrap leather I just cut some strips for
the sides that are gonna go along the
side of your face equal lengths for
either side and then as we saw before I
cut out the outline of the shape that
piece is a little bit extra and then I
ran these fasteners here through the
other side
that's it this is what you're left with
now keep in mind that you don't have to
do this exact bill this is just to give
you an idea of something you can do
using some off-the-shelf items at the
Halloween store or at a hardware store
or hobby store these are just some
simple elements you can pull off the
shelves repurpose them and with some
creative paintwork I'm gonna put it in
you know really what sells it is the
paint Jeff several layers of paint I
just keep going start dark and go
lighter and lighter and lighter using
metallic paints start off with a flat
black and or our bronze or era or like a
deep brown and just keep doing dry
brushing over it or you could do some
light passes with some for spray paint
but the idea is you can start dark and
then go lighter and lighter so that the
the highlighted pieces the pieces that
stick out the furthest are highlighted
and the brightest I will say that a lot
of these little knickknacks these little
pieces that I glued on there or attached
to riveted can be a little expensive but
you can buy them in like a pack so
you'll have more than just what they
came with so in total this match
probably wound up costing about 18 to
the 20 dollars but I also have leftover
items so if I wanted to make another
master me pin to other mass I have
enough stuff to do that and I had tons
of stuff like pulled out when I was
gonna start this and I only used a
fraction of the pieces that I pulled out
that I thought I was gonna use you know
as you're building is you're kind of
working if you're working organically
and you're just kind of like I'm just
gonna take these elements and see what I
can build it's kind of a fun way to do
it you've got it you know discover
things as you go along you can't be like
I should this piece looks really cool
here or something you thought you were
gonna do you change your mind and you're
like oh actually I
we couldn't cooler to go in this
direction it's showed up in the video or
not but I use a piece of elastic to
connect the the two pieces of leather
you don't have to use elastic it was an
easy way to make it fit and stretch onto
anybody's face and you just cover it up
with this other scrap piece of leather
and you know but if you wanted you could
put buckles on here and have it be
adjustable again this is just kind of
give you an idea of some of the things
that you could do and I hope it inspires
you to go out and build some stuff so
thanks again for watching and see you
next time I hope you guys enjoy this
episode once again I'm sorry I didn't
have anything brand-new for you guys but
I promise that next week I will have a
fresh new episode and as we're going
into Halloween I thought I'd be cool if
you guys got me some more suggestions of
something you'd like to see me build for
Halloween a costume or a prop so leave
me your suggestions let me know and I'll
choose one for October and build it so
tune in for that and thanks again so
much for watching